for the showdown between Game of Thrones
season 1 and House of the Dragon season
1 we're going to compare these two shows
in five categories and see which ones
they exceed in it may be pretty obvious
to some people that Game of Thrones
season 1 is better but how does it stack
up against the beginning of House of the
dragon and how close are they in terms
of quality and how they started their
own shows so first let's dive into the
efficiency of setting up story elements
fight both Game of Thrones and House of
the dragon have to do a lot of setup
since the world of Westeros is massive
and there are dozens of characters that
are integral to the plots these are
introductory Seasons so the biggest
obstacle from a writing standpoint is to
educate the audience but not in a boring
manner this includes all the characters
the different houses political
allegiances motivations for the
characters and geography so any show
taking on this task is extremely
difficult once you venture into the
territory of too much Exposition you'll
quickly lose your audience to boredom
boom both got and hot tea don't fall
into these pitfalls and handle their
setup extremely well between the two
shows I think Game of Thrones takes on
the bigger burden since there are more
characters and they have to deal with
more perspectives and subplots around
the world after the first couple of
episodes it splinters into net and
King's Landing Tyran getting taken to
the veil Jon Snow at the Night's Watch
and Rob Stark and brand back in
Winterfell it's a lot harder to juggle
multiple plot lines than having a couple
of main ones that follow a few key
characters you have to balance each
episode and make them feel satisfying
despite only having a very limited
amount of time along with having just
enough time to build up each subplot to
have a good resolution by the finale as
opposed to House of the Dragon where
each episode has one General Arc that
everyone goes through together and you
don't really have to worry about
balancing a bunch of different
perspectives because from a writing
point of view you have to be very
particular about how much screen time
each subplot will require I wouldn't say
that either of these methods of
Storytelling is better than the other
but Game of Thrones has to tell a more
expansive story with like five plot
lines and that even gets more numerous
later on then there's also the factor of
more characters and by having more
characters that then introduces the need
to set up new houses and political
allegiances in House of the Dragon you
really only need to know about the
targaryens the high Towers the strongs
and the valerions meanwhile in Game of
Thrones season 1 the houses that are
integral to the story include the Starks
baratheons Lannisters targaryens house
Aaron and two other cultures that aren't
houses but are still relevant like the
night Swatch and the Dothraki got season
1 is naturally more ambitious in terms
of its scale and because of that I think
it deserves some extra points within
this category so now the question arises
in that which show executes its given
introductory material better and to me
that's pretty much equal I think both
shows expertly make their setup
intriguing and they do it in slightly
different ways for Game of Thrones they
do have more traditional form of
character introduction and there is
expository dialogue however they quickly
hook you into the show with an
engrossing mystery and an insane plot
twist a bran getting pushed out of a
window along with the opening scene
being the literal definition of a hook
where the first thing you witness is the
white walkers right away you're given a
taste of what's to come and the larger
conflict within the world so any
Exposition you may get bogged down by is
instantly forgiven by the story getting
a major Catalyst that Sparks the
interest of the audience in the
exposition we do get within the first
couple of episodes is always interesting
and as quickly and efficiently done some
examples include Ned Stark executing the
deserter who ran away which both pays
off their first scene and sets up the
code of honor that Ned lives by the
archery scene remember quickly learned
the dynamic between most of the
characters through primarily actions and
expressions like these quick glances
between Catelyn and Jon and most of the
dialogue is more personally driven that
has a lot of subtexts like Robert
talking about how much he loved lyanna
and Tyrion talking John for Tyrion he's
not giving a monologue that introduces
himself but instead the advice he gives
and how he acts around Jon and others
gives us a perfect illustration as to
who he is and we can quickly put
together that he's a black sheep of the
Lannisters for House of the Dragon it
doesn't really feel like we get formal
introductions and the writers don't hold
our hands we get ushered into this story
and the writers don't make up any
mechanics to naturally introduce us to
everyone like how in Game of Thrones
Robert Baratheon Ventures down to
Winterfell and each character
essentially introduces themselves and we
have someone like Arya being obsessed
with different characters shouting out
something like this
could you please shut up House of the
Dragon starting point feels like an
ordinary day and we're witnessing these
characters carry out their normal
business and through this in some minor
form of conflict introduction the
characters immediately take their shape
by how they react to it along with the
fact that the writers prioritizes select
few main characters for the audience to
really get to know instead of trying to
give everyone a moment to shine before
they go off on their own Adventures like
in Game of Thrones there are multiple
characters within the first episode of
hot tea that the writers don't really
bother to set up and that's perfectly
fine because the story isn't about them
yet House of the Dragon may not have a
crazy turning point in the story like a
major betrayal to distract people from a
lot of developments and the story
focuses more on character-related drama
that's what the first season of House of
the Dragon is focused on at the end of
the day so to say whether or not Game of
Thrones or House of the Dragon is better
at introducing story elements I think
it's about even however I'd give the
slight Edge to Game of Thrones for
having to take on a bigger load in
setting up material just barely because
of this Game of Thrones wins in this
category since we talked a little bit
about the story within the first couple
of episodes let's go into the general
plot of these two seasons and see which
one has the better story as discussed
prior House of the Dragon is more
concentrated on building characters and
their stories as opposed to the plot
constantly going crazy then for Thrones
it does put a lot of focus on characters
but the story does go on a wild ride for
the first four seasons the plot is like
lightning in a bottle and is more than
Perfection it's always going down
surprising directions it's very
unpredictable and every plot twist
drastically changes the landscape to the
point that the show keeps evolving House
of the Dragon is more straightforward in
comparison which is obviously not a bad
thing but when compared to Game of
Thrones it's kind of rough because in
terms of plot twists that drastically
changed the story we have the death of
Sir Harwin the death of luceris and
technically the fake out death of Sir
Leonard all of these events change the
story to a big degree and there are
other shocking moments like the death of
vaman's but that doesn't have as big of
an impact as he may think he dies and
the story doesn't change that much as a
result and that's not to say it's a bad
moment and it was great when looking at
Game of Thrones season 1 we have bran
getting pushed out of a window Catelyn
kidnapping Tyrion Jaime attacking Ned
Ned finding out the truth about Cersei
and Jaime Bobby Beacon and killed Ned
getting betrayed his death viserys's
death Khal drogo's death the season is
flat out stacked and there are even more
than the ones I listed but I physically
can't keep going because I'm running out
of breath the twists are so massive and
even check up the storytelling medium
like killing the main character it's
just staggering how many plot twists
George R Martin was able to cram into
this season and it's even crazier how
he's able to keep this up over the next
three seasons now the reason why I'm
focusing so much on plot to us is that
both Game of Thrones and House of the
Dragon perfect every other story element
to the the point that I have to find
some major differences to set them apart
another one of those differences in
favor of House of the Dragon is that I
think the depth of character work is a
bit deeper I don't think this Gap is as
big in relation to the plot twist Gap
but there are certain character arcs
like viserys that hits an emotional
depth that got season 1 doesn't get to
it has the death of Ned Stark and that
was very shattering but that's more of a
shocking twist rather than character
building the death of visceros isn't
necessarily the sad part and instead
it's a slow deterioration of his body
and overall image and how that impacts
his relationships seeing loved ones
wither away is extremely depressing
because it's basically a death that
lasts a long duration instead of lasting
one quick moment with so much of that
agonizing pain slowly building up over
time so does the amount of sympathy that
surrounds them viserys's Journey hits
this narrative aspect to a perfect tee
along with the makeup Department
applying an astonishing amount of detail
to his visual Decay from the color of
his skin slowly changing his hair
starting to thin his skin and body parts
succumbing to rot the way he walks
breathes and acts are also detailed to
the point that it's one of the best
performances with an all of Game of
Thrones then through all of this tragedy
we have a light at the end of the tunnel
and it's the absolute cherry on top and
that's the last supper words can't
describe the amount of wholesome and
sweet energy that radiate from the scene
now I should be saving all this for the
characters category later on but I think
it's important to bring up the fact that
house of the Dragon has some outstanding
story focused character developments if
hot tea had this aspect along with some
more game-changing plot twists then I
think it could match the first season of
Game of Thrones however there is one
more narrative aspect of House of the
dragon that brings it down a bit and
that's the time jumps and it's not all
of them doing time jumps is generally
fine within storytelling but when you
are intentionally leaving out
development in between that time that is
crucial for certain story arcs then you
run into issues the whole point of a
time Jump is to skip over over a
duration of time that doesn't have much
plot progression in House of the Dragon
it feels like the craters are more using
time jumps because HBO refuses to make
more than 10 episodes for a season
because of this there are consequences
like plot threads not continuing and
leaving the audience confused or leaving
out key character developments this in
turn tarnishes the payoff from these
plot lines and is the main reason why I
think episode 6 is the worst of the
season this is a minor issue that
primarily impacts one episode and a
couple others but we're comparing this
to the Masterpiece that is Game of
Thrones season one and there I think the
story is just way more captivating than
it is in Hot D it's a perfect storm of a
murder mystery entangled in a web of
political conspiracies and this is just
one of the plots of the first season
John Danny and Tyrion all have fun story
arcs in the season and all these
together along with the insane number of
twists make the general plot better than
House of the Dragon let's take a break
from talking about narrative elements
and compare the production quality
between these two Seasons right away it
may be a little unfair because House of
the dragon has a budget of about 20
million dollars per episode while Game
of Thrones had about 6 million dollars
per episode in season one but I'm not
going to hold that against Game of
Thrones too much and we'll try to take
into account that they're playing at a
disadvantage if anything though 6
million per episode in 2011 was still a
big budget the first production aspect
that I think has the biggest difference
is the cinematography House of the
Dragon looks much more cinematic than
Game of Thrones shots have moodier
lighting and seem more planned in
execution there's a sharp and warm color
gray that seems like it has more
contrast and the black levels are a bit
lower the aspect ratio is different and
has black bars instead of the full
screen presentation and lastly it feels
like there are more Dynamic camera moves
whether that be rack focuses or Dolly
shots and there are a lot more shots
that incorporate a shallow Focus or at
least submerges you into the acting in
the first season of Game of Thrones
visually only a few scenes stand out to
me which are the execution of Ned Stark
and how we were put into the headspace
of Ned through close-ups along with the
audio design helping with that tearing
in the sky cell which is uplifted by the
VFX and then Varys and Littlefinger
talking in the Great Hall which really
doesn't have anything special shot-wise
and is mainly carried by the set piece
and how Grand it is most of these iconic
visuals tend to have another aspect that
carries them while in House of the
Dragon ordinary dialogue scenes look
gorgeous I keep going back to this scene
in episode 2 where Allison consoles
ranera by candlelight the warm light
that hugs their faces as they pour out
emotions to one another as such a
precious visual delight and this isn't
just one occurrence because House of the
dragon has a big collection of beautiful
looking dialogue scenes in almost every
scene there's at least one shot that
sticks with me whether it be this dollar
shot on the beach this unnecessarily
artsy shot that spins around a cup while
it's being filled Allison having her
silhouette highlighted by the golden
rays of the sunlight the this close-up
of viserys's rotting finger or literally
any shot from the Dragonstone
confrontation because the atmosphere is
so tense with the fog and the sunset
lighting and hey guess what all these
examples were pulled from just half of
one episode and I think that alone
highlights the fact of how consistently
great the cinematography is in this show
Game of Thrones in comparison isn't as
impressive because it feels a lot more
naturalistic it doesn't feel like
there's a cinematic color grade to it
and most of the footage is generally
shot with a deeper Focus there's even a
big visual difference if you go later
into the show where there's more
dramatic lighting and everything else I
mentioned while talking about House of
the Dragon is present for season 1 there
really isn't anything wrong with this
style and it gets the job done it's just
since we're comparing the style to
something that's more cinematic I think
the Cinematic option will be better
looking at the VFX of season 1 I think
it still holds up extremely well
primarily because it's used to properly
execute the skill of the World by
showing off its fictional locations like
the wall and numerous exotic kingdoms
season 1 is still able to pass as high
quality television for today's standards
and even though they don't have massive
dragons walking around I think the VFX
is still really good the sets as well
are still very impressive and the first
time you walk into the throne room you
are always Blown Away by how massive it
is proportionally compared to House of
the Dragon since they have different
budgets I think Game of Thrones is
pretty similar in terms of VFX and
production design because on a
technicality House of the Dragon will
always be better in these aspects
because of the higher budget but I think
it's very commendable That Game of
Thrones is able to give them a run for
their money there's also another small
issue with got smaller budget in the
first season and that's the fact that
they weren't able to execute the battles
from a spectacle and action standpoint
it would have been really cool to see
them but I think from a narrative
standpoint David and Dan were still able
to make it work if anything I think this
again goes to show how Rock Solid the
story is in season one however this
round for production quality goes to
House of the Dragon
one aspect between these two shows that
I've been keeping track of is the
dialogue because House of the Dragon
actually has some really well written
dialogue given that it doesn't have much
in the source material the way people
speak feels accurate to the period and
doesn't feel out of place there are
enough quotable lines that will keep
anyone satisfied and each character is
expressed perfectly for the dialogue
they are given especially Damon
Targaryen she could have her out to now
stuffed in her father's mouth along with
his withered cop let's end this Mama's
far
House of the Dragon in comparison to
most shows blows them away but when it
comes to Game of Thrones I think this is
the golden standard for outstanding
dialogue and almost every scene there
will be a standout line that will
immediately imprint on you just now if I
tell you to think about your favorite
line in season 1 of Game of Thrones
you'll probably immediately think of
Love is the death of Duty a lion doesn't
concern himself with the opinions of the
sheep when you play the game of thrones
you win or you die or literally anything
that comes out of tyrion's mouth my
brother has a sword and I have my mind
and the mind needs books like a sword
needs a whetstone since it's been like a
month since the end of House of the
Dragon there aren't as many lines that
have stuck with me in comparison to Game
of Thrones if you ask the same question
to recount some of the best lines from
Hot D you'd probably be able to think of
a few but not as many as I'd expect for
got that's not to say that the iconic
lions and House of the Dragon are worse
in particular I just think that George R
Martin outclassed the writers and his
usage of literary devices were amazing
especially with Tyrion the man just
oozes so much wisdom and the character
on his own is a mouthpiece for some of
the best dialogue in the show without
Tyrion then maybe House of the Dragon
would have a slim chance but I think
Tyrion is like the sarbarrassing selmia
fighting but for dialogue every scene he
is in his dialogue puts you into a
trance that makes you immediately fall
in love with his character essentially A
Perfect combo for his personality and
the writing surrounding him that
masterfully brings him to life the only
character that comes close and has the
dragon in terms of charming Charisma is
Damon and he doesn't really have many
iconic lines unfortunately any seemingly
good dialogue that surrounds his
character is more carried by the great
acting from Matt Smith meanwhile in Game
of Thrones I'm always impressed by the
intelligent and meaningful lines that
are always jumping from the script I am
putting a lot of emphasis on iconic
lines and that's because I think both
shows nail all other aspects for
dialogue expertly to the point that I
essentially have to do an to arms race
for memorable lines and when it comes to
that race Game of Thrones wins so even
though Geo team wins in that aspect I
think hot diesel has great dialogue that
is able to sit next to Game of Thrones
without anyone feeling like there's a
massive disparity in quality
for the last category I wanted to save
what I would think would be the most
interesting one and that's the
characters I'd also classify this
category as being the most subjective
because this category will be skewed
more by which characters you are drawn
to the most to lay out some facts right
away Game of Thrones has more characters
than House of the dragon and not just
more Side characters but main characters
too now I wouldn't say that having more
is better because that means you have to
divide your time much more across the
show instead of being able to focus on
the select few main characters however I
don't think any of the main characters
are heard as a result of this in Game of
Thrones they just may not hit the
absolute highs that visares Arc was able
to get to now you can argue that Ned
Stark would rival that but I think the
plot point of his death makes his
character naturally more iconic than the
character himself because when looking
at Ned he doesn't have as deep and
expansive of an arc as viserys does he's
a man of Honor who chooses to go down
the rabbit hole of the mystery of Don
Aaron's death and along the way he meets
his demise the one thing that actually
changed about his character was in the
dungeons before his execution he learns
to drop his immense Pride surrounding
his honor and chooses to try to save his
daughters in an act that destroys what
defines him that's obviously great but
in comparison to viserys there's a lot
more going on internally and even
externally a king who tries his hardest
to continue the Glorious terrain of King
jaharis but is constantly making
mistakes that worsens the world around
him these mistakes Define viserys
because he wants to make everyone happy
to the point that he loses sight of the
ramifications of his actions like
preemptively making renira his Heir
allowing the stepsons to become a
festering issue choosing to be ignorant
towards or near a having bastards and
allowing the Divide between the greens
and the blacks to grow viserys is
constantly changing his mind and seeing
him reflect on his mistakes creates
solid moments of character developments
that layer of confidence in being King
melts away and we see this frail man who
like anyone else regularly has regrets
and Sorrows our image of his search
changes immensely from episode to
episode and in most of them we tend to
learn something integral tied to the
essence of his character I can go on for
a while about viserys and I did go on
for a bit in the general plot section
but to say the least I think he's one of
the most captivating leads between the
two shows the rest of the main
characters in House of the Dragon I
don't think are able to get to the peak
that viserys was able to get to like
runira had an intense journey through
adolescence and her adulthood was even
more hectic but I'd argue that Daenerys
had just as good of an arc for season
one seeing her go from a fully
suppressed and scared child to an
independent woman who builds the
confidence to stand up to the oppressive
men around her and become a leader was a
great journey it may not go as in depth
as renera emotionally since she had more
screen time however I think Game of
Thrones is able to utilize that smaller
amount of screen time for each of its
main characters really well like Tyrion
John Danny Ned Cersei Jaime Arya and
many more feel just flesh out enough for
the audience to love them and it doesn't
feel like anything is missing for us to
understand what they are going through
also since the budget for the show is
smaller that means that most scenes tend
to be dialogue scenes so we actually
have more time within the show for
character building than we did in House
of the Dragon since there isn't as much
action I know I said that quantity of
characters within Game of Thrones
doesn't make it better than hot D but I
think they were able to hit that hard
goal of quantity and quality while House
of the dragon has a smaller quantity but
just as much quality and if not a bit
more I love Damon Allison Otto Rainier
and viserys but it essentially stops
there for the S tier characters also
since Game of Thrones naturally has more
subplots they are able to introduce more
Side characters without it feeling
overwhelming because if you have the
same amount of characters in Game of
Thrones for just two main plot lines
like in House of the Dragon then it will
become very crowded for this this
category House of the Dragon is able to
give Game of Thrones a run for its money
but ultimately it's almost impossible to
beat the perfect Ensemble of characters
for Game of Thrones if they were able to
give the rest of the main characters in
hotty and equally orgasmic character Arc
as viserys had then maybe it would be
better than Game of Thrones season 1.
even though House of the Dragon lost in
four of the five categories it came very
close to matching the quality that his
season 1 of Game of Thrones given that
the story is supposed to get even
crazier in season 2 of House of the
Dragon then I won't be surprised if it's
able to exceed the greatness of season 2
of got thank you for watching and let me
know in the comments if you want me to
do any more of these versus Style videos
foreign